sup everyone Walter Lopez gainsbourg
media manager here and I'm Cindy tank
unit producer we're showing you
especially preview the brand-new
gamespot homepage we got your feedback
heard what you had to say so here's a
quick preview but what you expect you
probably already notice the platform bar
at the top of the page that we added a
couple months ago whether you want to
jump ahead or you're waiting greatness
you're always one click away from all
the news reviews and videos for your
platform of choice the most obvious
change to the homepage by layer top
slots where we spotlight the biggest
stories of the day check back often you
never know what news might be blowing up
right under the top slots is the latest
on gamespot we've redesigned a section
to help you filter through everything
that hits the site daily finding what
you want on the front page whether
you're looking for news videos features
for the most popular post with
streamlined and easier than ever just to
the right you'll find the brand new
review module this section is updated
with our latest game reviews and their
scores or you can filter by platform
speaking of which ever wonder what the
most popular games on gamespot are we're
showcasing the top 10 games on the site
we've recently revamped our visual
programming but don't sweat it the new
schedule is right on the homepage never
miss another episode of multiple players
with Chris waters and friends which just
switched over to Monday's for the point
with the ever-charming Daniel dryer new
episodes now on Fridays last but far
from least the bottom of the page is
where the most popular features and
videos are on display it really doesn't
get any easier to find with your fellow
gamespot readers hyped for just click to
join the conversation we've already
started rolling out the homepage and
everyone should see the shiny news site
and upcoming weeks and as always we want
to hear what you think the good the bad
and of course though we'd jump into the
forums and tweet at gamespot we're
always listening